pocas veces he visto tan lleno el mundo
está en el parlamento Alemán como este
jueves al mediodía hora local para el
discurso del Rey Carlos ante el pleno Es
la primera vez que un monarca se dirige
al pleno del mundo stack y de ahí que el
discurso del Rey Carlos fuera seguido
muy de cerca por los líderes de los
órganos constitucionales de Alemania por
los ministros del gobierno actual por la
gran mayoría de parlamentarios y también
por una larga lista de invitados en La
Tribuna de visitantes el Rey Carlos
habló buena parte de su discurso en
alemán resaltando las relaciones
históricas entre Reino Unido y Alemania
pero también enfatizando puntos en los
que los dos países trabajan de la mano
actualmente en particular resaltó el Rey
Carlos el trabajo conjunto entre Reino
Unido y Alemania en lo que se refiere a
las posturas en la Guerra de Ucrania es
muy probable que el discurso del Rey
Carlos y en particular de que hablara en
Alemania bien recibido por la gran
mayoría de los parlamentarios en
Alemania si bien también De antemano se
escucharon algunas críticas de parte del
partido de la izquierda un pequeño
partido de la oposición que no ve con
buenos ojos la invitación del Rey Carlos
al parlamento sin embargo para la gran
mayoría Es probable que este discurso Se
Ha Visto como una manera de reforzar y
de renovar las relaciones bilaterales
entre el Reino Unido y Alemania